[Music]
[Applause]
so happy to be in the bubble aren't you
all the luckiest people in the world oh
my god hi Oprah so we have been so
excited and eagerly anticipating this
day this campus has been buzzing since
the announced announcement was made last
week that you'd be coming here and I
received a buzz I'm so glad you know I
still have buzz so good I received a lot
of support and advice from my friends
and that was really great and I just
wanted to say I think the best advice I
heard was don't worry Amanda if you mess
up Oprah can just interview herself so
if I falter feel free to ask yourself
some questions and while I love again
but to get things started I want I
thought we'd frame today's talk with
framing three sections with quotes of
yours
that you shared after wrapping up your
25th season and final season of The
Oprah Winfrey Show and I thought some of
these quotes
I mean you share so much wisdom but
these really spoke to me and thought
would be a great way to frame our
discussion so this first one that I will
read for everyone and for you so you
don't have to strain your neck
um you have to know what sparks the
light in you so that you in your own way
can illuminate the world so I wanted to
take this time to talk about your early
career and how you discovered your
calling so let's go back to when your
college age did you know that you wanted
to get into TV and media specifically no
I did not
I thought that I was going to be a
teacher I was in my sophomore class at
Tennessee State University I had already
been working in radio since I was 16 and
my I remember I was in mr. Cox's drawing
class for theatre and I was terrible
drawer he said I couldn't draw a
straight line with a ruler and and I got
a call in that class
from a guy at the local station CBS and
he'd been calling me several times when
I was working in radio so I started
working in radio at 16 I won the Miss
fire-prevention contest another long
story
and so when I went back to the station
to pick up my prize some guy said would
you like to hear your voice on tape I
said sure and I started reading this
copy on tape they called everybody in
the building said hear this kid read I
was 16 they hired me in radio so I was
in radio at 16 and so I started getting
calls about my freshman year to come
into television I'd never thought about
it and still was living at home and
couldn't figure out how it managed those
I had biology at one o'clock and so I
couldn't figure out how I would be able
to manage my schedule and mr. Cox said
to me the one same-same professor said
you can't draw a straight line with a
ruler he said I came back from from
taking this phone call and he said who
was that I said there's this guy at CBS
he keeps calling me he wants me to
interview for job and mr. Cox said that
is why you go to school fool
so that CBS can call you that is why
you're in school so I said you do you
leave now and go call him back and and I
did and I was hired in television not
knowing anything about it
mm-hmm having in mind Barbara Walters
but thinking okay I can do that not
knowing how to write or film or anything
and I think it was because it was the it
was the times and I literally had
somebody who was willing to work with me
that I managed to to find my way but I
had to find my way because the reporting
never really fit me and what did work
for me I'm this old I'm so old that when
I started that it was a year of live
action cam and so it's like video
cameras live until the news stations
would do a live a live shot they would
throw to somebody live even if nothing
was going on just so they could say live
action cam and what I found is I wasn't
so good at the writing part but if I was
just standing up and talking about what
it just happened it was really good and
then I started to feel so I started in
nineteen working in television became an
anchor immediately afterwards my father
still had an eleven o'clock curfew can
you believe such a thing that I am I am
the ten o'clock anchor
in Nashville Tennessee I am the woman on
the newscast reading the news and my
father would say be home by 11:00 and I
take Edie the news is on at 10:00 he
goes in it's off at 10:30 so beyond
11:00 so I had a very strict very strict
father so anyway I
I could feel inside myself that
reporting was not the right thing for me
even though I was happy to have the job
right I got an offer to go to Atlanta I
was making $10,000 a year in 1971 but
still in college so I was thinking I was
doing pretty good I got an offer to go
to Atlanta for 40,000 which I thought
it's over I'm gonna make $40,000 and my
boss at the time said to me you do not
know what you don't know and you need to
stay here until you can learn to write
better until you can perfect your craft
as as a journalist and so I
he said and we can't give you 40 but we
can give you 12 so so I stayed and you
know the reason why I stayed is because
I could feel inside myself that even
though the forty was alluring at the
time that he was absolutely right so to
make a long story short because I'd be
here all day just talking about how it
all came about I started listening to
what felt like the truth for me a couple
of years later I moved to Baltimore I
could feel that as a reporter and by
this time 22 I'm making twenty two
thousand I'm at my best friend Gail
there who said oh my god can you imagine
if you thirteen you're making thirty
thousand
and then your 40 minutes forty days we
actually had that conversation in the
bath so this is I started to feel that
reporting wasn't for me but I had my
father I had my friends everybody was
saying oh my god you're an anchorwoman
you're on TV I mean you can't give up
that job and when I was by the time I
was making twenty five my father goes
well you just hit the jackpot
you're not gonna make my money as man
that's just it so I was torn between
what the world was saying to me and what
I felt to be the truth for myself
it felt like an unnatural act for me
reporting although I knew that a lot of
people it was glamorous and I started to
just inside myself think what do I
really want to do what I really want to
do and I will say this knowing what you
don't want to do is the best possible
place to be if you don't know what to do
because knowing what you don't want to
do leads you to figure out what is it
you you really do want to do so you
discovered talk then right around that
time I didn't discover talk I was being
I got demoted they wanted to fire me but
I was I was under contract for didn't
and they didn't want to give up the
twenty five thousand so they were trying
to keep me on to the end of the year so
they put me on this talk this is way
life works they could be on a talk show
to try to avoid having to pay me the
contract out and the moment I sat on the
talk show interviewing the Carvel ice
cream man and his multiple flavors I
knew that I had found home for myself
because when I was a news reporter it
was so unnatural for me you know to
cover somebody's tragedies and
difficulties and then to not to have
feel anything for it and I would go back
after a fire and I would take them
blankets and then I would get a note
from my boss saying what the hell are
you doing you're just supposed to read
can't be that it cannot be that
empathetic and it felt unnatural for me
so if I were to put it in business terms
it or
or to leave you with the message that
the truth is I have from the very
beginning listened to my instinct all of
my best decisions in life have come
because I was attuned to what really
felt like the next right move for me and
so it didn't feel right I knew that I
wouldn't be there forever I never even
learned the streets in Baltimore because
I thought I was there longer than I
thought I was there eight years I should
have learned the street but I kept
saying myself so when I got the call to
come to Chicago hmm after you know
starting with a with a co-anchor and and
working and in talk for several years I
knew that it was the right thing to do
and I knew that if I'd even if I didn't
succeed because at the time there was a
there was a guy named Phil Donahue yeah
was the king of talk and was on in
Chicago and every single person except
my best friend Gail said you're gonna
fail every single person when I love it
my bosses by this time thought I was
terrific and said you're gonna you're
you're walking into a land mile you're
gonna fail you're gonna fail Chicago's a
race the city you're black you're not
gonna make everything to keep me saying
that you then offered me a car and an
apartment and all this stuff and I said
no if I fail then I will find out what
is the next thing for me what is the
next to thing for me it felt right to
you see what I felt like this is now the
move I need to make and I was not one of
those people you know all of my the
people who worked with me in news it
would have their tapes and they'd have
their stories and they'd have you know
resumes ready I didn't have any of that
because I knew that the time would come
where I would wear what I need it would
show up for me okay and when that showed
up I was ready because my definition of
luck is preparation meeting the moment
of opportunity and I was prepared to be
able to step into that that world of
talk in a way that I knew I could do it
great so often
your career I'm sure you are a minority
perhaps is the only woman the only black
person the only person from a poor
family this affect you on your
professional path and how did you
navigate situations in which you might
have felt more alone and now how did
that impact how you lead and how you
might help people who may be feeling
that same thing okay man that's a lot of
questions I figured I had you here I was
gonna I was gonna ask for us if I could
and Samantha went deep on me there for a
minute
back up sister girl
come on back up first one is so how did
you navigate situations in which you
might have felt more alone always the
only only woman in the room still
walk-in only woman in the room and
there's a roomful of white men usually
older thrills me just thrills me I just
I just love it usually the only black
person in the room also never really
concerned me because I don't look at
people through color I didn't get to be
where I am by and Who I am by looking at
the color of people's skin I really
literally took Martin Luther King at his
word and understand that the content of
a person's character and refused to let
anybody else do that to me so I love it
just love it and there's a wonderful
phrase by Maya Angelou from a poem that
she wrote called to our grandmothers
that she says when I come as one but I
stand as 10,000 so when I walk into a
room and particularly before I have
something really challenging to do or
I'm gonna be in a circumstance where I
feel I'm going to be you know up against
some difficulties I will literally sit
and I will call on that 10,000 I will
call on that the ancestors I will call
on those people who've come before me I
will call on the women who forged a path
I might be able to sit in the room with
all of those white men and love it so
much I I call on I call on that because
I know that my being where I am and
first of all being who I am and where I
am didn't come just out of myself that I
come from a heritage and so I own that
and I step into that room not just as
myself but I bring all of that in that
that energy with me so it has never been
an issue for me except when I was I
think 23 still working in working in
Baltimore I gone to my boss and said
that the guy who was working with me
Coco my co-host on the people are
talking show was making more money than
I and we were we were co-hosts so I went
to my boss and I said this is in 1970 so
I was older than 23 it was 1979 80 and I
said I just would like to you know how
intimidating it is to go to the boss in
the first place but I'm gonna go we're
not gonna stand up for myself and I said
Richard's making more money than I am
and I and I don't think that's fair
because we're doing the same job we sit
in the same show we did say and my
general manager said why should you make
as much money as he and I said because
we're doing the same job and he said but
he has children
do you have children and I said no he
said well he has to pay for college
education si has he owns his own home do
you own your home I said no he said he
has a mortgage to pay he has insurance
yes sir
do you have that no so tell me why you
why do you need the same amount of money
and I said thank you for your time and I
left I left I didn't complain about it I
didn't file a suit about it I knew that
in that moment it was time for me to go
and that I started the process for
myself of preparing myself where you
will not be here long you are not going
to be able to get what you need
I had a boss at the time who was
african-american and had just been for
the first time made an assistant news
director and was drunk with power drunk
with power and felt it his I think I
don't know I think he woke up in the
morning thinking of things he could do
to harass me I decided not to file a
suit against it because I knew at the
time I would lose right that no good
would come of it that I would be
blackballed in television that it would
turn into a major thing and I knew I
didn't have long to stay there I had a
vision for what the future was even
though I couldn't place exactly where my
future would be I knew who held the
future because I am really guided by a
force that's bigger than myself I know
that my being here on the planet is not
just of my own so you use that as
momentum to just leave cut your losses
anyway there will come a time yeah you
were right I will be sitting in the same
room and it happened like in the late
90s I had the Oprah show and I ran into
that guy Lord Jesus
now oh one of the sweetest moments I've
ever had oh go ahead okay here we go
so right now as we sit here we're about
five miles from Facebook I'm Sheryl
Sandberg and last year she published the
book lean in and it's got an incredible
traction it had some you know criticism
as well and I was wondering if you were
to write a book on women in careers
what would your title be mine would be
actually mine wouldn't be lean in it
would be step up and into yourself
because this is the truth there is no
real doing in the world without being
first for me being your presence your
connection to yourself and that which is
greater than yourself is far more
important than what you do but also is
the thing that fuels what you do and I
know that one of the things that is so
important for what happens here at the
Graduate School is that you have leaders
who are self actualized and understand
what your contribution to change the
world can be you can only do that if you
know yourself you can only do that
unless you take unless you you cannot do
it unless you take the time to actually
know who you are and why you are here
now I happen to know for sure that every
human being comes comes called and that
the calling goes beyond the definition
of what your job is that there is an
innate there is an innate supreme moment
of destiny for everybody and that's why
when I was in Baltimore I could feel
this isn't it isn't it and then in
Chicago after 25 years of success on the
show I started to feel this isn't it
there's something more something more
something more but calling me to what is
supreme moment and everybody has that
and you cannot fulfill it unless you
have a level of self-awareness to be
connected to what is the inner voice or
the instinct I call it your emotional
GPS system that allows you to make the
best decisions for yourself in every
decision that has profited me has come
from me listening to that inner voice
first in every just gotten into a
situation where I was in trouble it's
because I didn't listen to it I overrode
that voice that instinct with my own
with my own head of my own thinking I
tried to rationalize it I tried to tell
myself but you know okay you're gonna
make a lot of money oh no and so I am I
sit here
you know profitable successful by all
the definitions of the world but what
really really really resonates deeply
with me is that I live a fantastic life
my inner life is really intact my I live
from the inside out and so everything
that I have I have because I let it be
fueled by who I am and what I realized
my contributions to the planet could be
and what my real contribution is it
looks like I'm it I was a talk-show host
it looks like you know I'm in the movies
it looks like you know I have a network
but my real contribution the reason why
I'm here is to help connect people to
themselves and the higher ideas of
consciousness I'm here to help raise
consciousness so my television platform
was to help raise consciousness in
beginning I didn't realize that I
thought oh my god I got a job and it
wasn't until I was interviewing the Ku
Klux Klan one day and can you imagine
all the great lessons come from things
that are there sometimes challenging I
was interviewing Ku Klux Klan and I
thought as an african-american oh I'm
gonna get them
gonna show for every Jewish person for
every person who's been discriminated
against and during the commercial break
I saw the Klan exchanging signals and
looks at each other and then something
inside that instinct I thought I am
doing nobody any good they are loving
this they are using me
I think I'm doing an interview they are
using me I did not know it at the time I
brought them on actually those same guys
back in the for my last year and they
told me that they used that show for
their recruitment I could feel that
happening and I made a decision after
that show I'll never do anything like
that again I'll never let my platform be
used and I will not used and at the time
in the 90s early 90s everybody was doing
confrontational television and I thought
I was above the fray because I'm not
like Jerry Springer I don't do that so
in my egoic delusion I thought because I
am not that bad I'm really not bad but I
was doing confrontational television I
thought I was exposing men with affairs
we happen to have a guy on who was
talking about how he'd had an affair
with his wife and he was crazy enough to
come on with his wife and his girlfriend
people asked me why do people do that
it's because nobody ever asked him so
you said would you come on with your
wife here you go friend he goes sure you
were thinking you're thinking so he
comes home with the wife and the
girlfriend this is a life-changing
moment for me the Klan and this woman
mm-hmm
the wife is there he's in the center and
the girlfriend and he tells his what he
announces we were live television at the
time and he announced that to to to the
world and to his wife that his
girlfriend was pregnant and I did you
see her face your mouths open like that
I did exactly that I went
my god and you could hear the gasp in
the audience anything and I literally
really it still makes my eyes water
think about I looked at her face and I
felt her humiliation I felt her shame I
felt it and I said never again I will
get out of television if I have to do
this and I went and I had a meeting with
the producers because I just had the
Klan before and I got the adulterers
here and some uplifting show let's say
and I said to the producers we are gonna
change we're gonna turn this around and
I am no longer gonna be used by
television I am going to use television
what a concept
I'm gonna use television as a force for
four I didn't say at the time for good I
said you know let's think about what we
want to say to the world and how we want
to use this as a platform to speak to
the world how do we want to see the
world change how do we want to impact
the world and then let all of our shows
really be focused and centered around
that I then said to the producers
exactly what I said to you backstage do
not bring me a show unless you have
fully thought out what is your intention
for doing it because if there is if
there's a religion or a mantra or law
that I live by I live by the third law
of motion in physics which is Stanford
which is
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction that is that as that
as that is my religion I know that what
I'm thinking and therefore going to act
on is going to come back to me in this
in a circular motion just like gravity
like what goes up comes down and so what
also propels the action is the intention
so I don't do anything without being
fully clear about why I intend to do it
because the intention is going to
determine the reaction the result or the
consequence in every circumstance I
don't care what it is so I said to my
producers come to me with your intention
at whatever it is whatever shows you're
proposing whatever ideas you're
proposing and then I will decide based
upon the intention do I really want to
do that is this how we want to use this
platform and that really is the secret
to why we were number one
all those years is because it was an
intention fueled intention based coming
out of purposeful programming yeah
that's what it was great and that's a
perfect segue to go to our second
section which I read this quote and it
just struck me as so true and I wanted
to delve into it I've talked to nearly
30,000 people on this show and all
30,000 had one thing in common they all
wanted validation I will tell you that
every single person you will ever meet
shares that common desire so Oprah you
are a true renaissance woman you know
you have your own network you had this
amazingly successful show for twenty
five years you've been in movies you are
one of the most important
philanthropists of our time so what are
the quality thinking around us
I'm just taking it all in I love it to
Zoey I love the mostest Renaissance
woman as you said that I want what does
that really mean I don't know but I like
it I was a history major I'm glad you
like it
what are the qualities of your
leadership that make you successful at
such diverse pursuits hmm and what works
for in one area that maybe doesn't work
in another well I tell you it works in
all areas because I my life is fueled by
my being
yeah and the being fuels to doing so I
come from a centered place I come from a
focused place I come from compassion
it's just it's just my nature I come
from a willingness to understand and to
be understood and I come from wanting to
to to connect I mean the secret of that
show for 25 years is that people could
see themselves in me all over the world
they could see themselves in me and even
as I became more and more financially
successful which was a big surprise to
me I was like oh I mean you got more
than that 30,000 more than 30,000 by the
time I was 30 so
so my but what I realized is through the
whole process because I'm grounded in my
own self that although I could have more
shoes my feet stayed on the ground
although I was wearing better shoes he's
cute today too so I could keep my feet
on the ground even though I could get
more shoes and I could understand I
could understand that it really was
because I was grounded I've done the was
doing and continue to this day to do the
consciousness work I work at staying
awake and being awakened is just another
word for spirituality but spirituality
throws people off and they think you
mean religion when I was hiring people
for my company for own looking for
presidents when people would come in I'd
say tell me what is your spiritual
practice and literally would throw out
people dog
well the put there I well I'm not
religious or I said I didn't ask you
about your religion I asked you what
your spiritual practice what do you do
to take care of yourself what do you do
to keep yourself centered what do you do
to that and you know one women started
crying you know that's not the person so
so to answer your question everything is
fueled that comes from me really wanting
to be a better person on earth and this
is what I know to be true the reason why
the show worked is because I understood
that that audience my viewers the people
who watched us every day and would come
and just like you all did get tickets
and they would come with their fight you
all just came across campus but that's
good too but people would come from all
over the world just to be there with
their aunts and their mothers and they
come with their cousins and there'd be a
few men and they're going what the hell
or saying well I went to Oprah with you
I went to Oprah
at least give me clear for three or four
weeks I went to over with you
I had such regard for that and I just
had a conversation with John Mackey who
runs Whole Foods and has written this
fabulous book you should get it called
conscious capitalism and he was talking
about how the investment in the
stakeholders the people who you are
serving that connection between the
people who you're trying to serve and
sell to is equally as important as the
people who you're buying from equally as
important as the people who are you know
supporting you financially as your
stockholders if you are you know you
know a public company so I always
understood that there really was no
difference between me and the audience
at times I might have had better shoes
but at the core the core of what really
matters that we are the same you know
how I know that because all of us are
seeking the same thing you're here at
this fabulous school and we'll go out
into the world and each pursue based
upon what you believe your talents are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being that's what you're looking for the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being and because I understand
that I understand that if you're working
in a bakery and that's where you want to
be and that may be that may be what
you've always wanted to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your gift then then that's
that's for you and there's no difference
between you and me except that's how
that's your platform that's your show
every day so my understanding of that
has allowed me to to reach everyone and
and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what I truly feel
and when I sit down to talk to somebody
whether I'm talking to a murderer
sat down I interviewed a guy who'd
killed his twin daughters I've
interviewed child molesters trying to
figure out what what it is what is what
it is they do and why they do it
obviously lots of people who've been
victimized through mountain molestation
presidents politicians Beyonce herself
they are at the end of every interview
the murderer - Beyonce the question
everybody asks that you mentioned is
what's that okay how was that everybody
says that and I now I just wait for it
is that okay
was that okay and when I finish I'll say
to you okay I'm gonna ask you to okay
you're very okay so what I started to
feel feel since is that there's a common
thread that runs through every interview
doesn't matter what it is or what it is
about everybody wants to know and this
is the truth all of your arguments are
really about the same thing it's about
did you hear me did you see me and did
what I say mean anything to you
that's what everything's about so the
reason why I left my boss's office when
I was asking for a raise I could I knew
he didn't hear nor see me neither and
that I was not gonna get the validation
that I need it now
I couldn't articulate that at the time I
just knew let me get out of here
but now I know I could feel inside
myself I'm not gonna get the validation
that I'm looking for I also know that's
what every human being is looking for
they're looking to know are you fully
here with me are you fully here or are
you distracted that's what you're that's
what your children want to know that's
what you're you're the people you work
for one two no that's what you want to
know is did you hear me and every
argument isn't about whatever it is you
think you're talking about it's really
about but can you hear me and many
people have even said it have you not
said it you're not hearing me
you're not hearing me so having having
that understanding and I would have to
say that the show one of the reasons why
I live such a fantastic life is because
I pay attention I pay attention to my
life and your life is your greatest
teacher every single thing that's
happening to you every day your your
Joy's yours your your sadness is your
challenges your worries your everything
is happening to bring you closer to in
here everything is trying to take you
home to yourself and when you're at home
with yourself when you're solidly there
connected to whatever you call creation
even if you don't call it anything
connected to an energy force that is
that has unlimited power for you when
you can connect it to that you you you
are your best my greatest one of my
greatest lessons came from a guy who
wrote a book called Selah so I was doing
them on the show and I started talking
this consciousness spiritual talk you
know two months after I started the show
and my producers were all be like oh god
there she goes again but I knew that
even though masses of people were not
tuning in for that that the whole
purpose of that platform was to try to
lift people up and now I have a network
and I can articulate what it is I'm
trying to do I'm trying to bring little
pieces of light into people's lives
because what is my job my job is not to
be an interviewer my job is not to be a
talk show host or just to own a network
I am here to raise the level of
consciousness to connect people to ideas
and stories so that they can see
themselves and live better lives thank
you
I want to shift gears and focus a bit on
plan are you worried about getting all
your stuff in and no we're doing great
we're just gonna keep going
I think everyone likes us right we're
good
okay so I watched your interview with
the Forbes conference on philanthropy
mm-hmm and you said something really
interesting which is that early on some
of your biggest mistakes in giving or
because you made emotional decisions
yeah and yet we learn here at the GSB
like one of the crucial messages we take
away with us is that it's really
important to be as you said before
self-aware to be understanding often to
share our emotions with others and you
yourself have been the master of you
know harnessing vulnerability with
yourself and your guests over the years
so how do you strike a balance between
emotion and logic how do you make sure
that you're making logical decisions
when you're giving oh these are so well
thought out okay well I would have to
say that you need both you need emotion
and you need logic so in the beginning I
was purely emotional made a lot of
mistakes I happened to be sitting I was
sharing this story with dean saloner
just before he came on I was sitting in
Nelson Mandela's living room and I'm not
just saying that's a name
I was actually sitting there he stayed
with him right I stayed with him for
stayed with him for ten ten days and as
I said to the Dean and Lisa I could have
I literally could have written a book
called 29 meals because I had 29 meals
with him at that particular time I
wished I had I didn't recorded so
something I think was that the second
meal or the tornado anyway so I was
sitting in Nelson sitting with with
Madiba and we were talking about how how
do you really make an impact in the
world and we were reading the paper and
we I'd reached a point where I was no
longer like oh my god
[Music]
because we were just sitting in silence
reading the paper and there was an
article in the paper about you know some
tragic situation and we both started
talking about the way to end poverty is
to me education and I said to him I
really at some point would like to build
a school over here and then he got up
and called the Minister of Education and
said get over here now
Oprah wants to build a school
and I was like well I was thinking about
it I didn't say I wanted to do it today
but so we literally started the process
now it was an emotional decision for me
in that I think philanthropy should come
out of you you're doing should come out
of your being everybody knows my story
as a poor Negro child growing up in
apartheid Mississippi and if it were not
for education and being born at the
right time because I was literally born
in the year of desegregation five years
before three years before two years
before nobody would have even had the
hope that my life could have been any
different so because I was born at that
time
and literally moved out of Mississippi
by the time I was in my first classroom
I was in kindergarten wrote my
kindergarten teacher a letter miss knew
I said Dumas knew I do not belong here
because I know a lot of big words and
then I wrote every big word I knew
elephant hippopotamus Mississippi
Nicodemus shadrach meshach had been to
go from the Bible so and then this news
says who did this I said I did so then
they marched me off to the principal's
office only time I was ever in their
principal's office
principal made me sit and write those
words again and I got myself out of
kindergarten into first grade like first
grade skip second grade hello her the
Renaissance began yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah
you've always had this conviction you've
oh it seems like you've always known who
you are even if you were I didn't belong
there we know that it's in kindergarten
you're sitting there that's what I'm
trying to listen your instincts you look
around and you see these kids they are
playing with some blocks I know
Nicodemus I do not think I belong in
here I do not belong in here so my point
is my point is education really opened
the door as we all know not gonna give
you the education speech how do you
change a person's life I had prior to
starting my school in South Africa I had
this big idea that I was going to
emotional and I was gonna take Oh a
hundred families out of the project some
green and green and I was gonna give
them a new life and I was gonna buy them
homes and stuff and that did not work it
would fail miserably I had a big sister
program that I started fail miserably so
I realized that for me first of all I
realized you don't change as you all are
recognizing through the seed program you
first have to change the way a person
thinks and sees themselves so you've got
to create a sense of aspiration a sense
of hopefulness so a person can see can
begin to even have a vision for a better
life and if you can't connect to that
then then you then you lose you lose and
they lose and it's just money after
money after money so for me it's using
my philanthropy to do what I have found
to be enormous ly helpful you know the
light in my life was education so for me
in the beginning when I started to make
money especially when it's published
everybody and their brother calls you
and then you've got to make a decision
am I gonna do what everybody else wants
me to do or am I going to bled by by who
I really am and I learned as will happen
to anybody who's successful in your
family
we'll start treating you like the First
National Bank and you've got to decide
you got to draw the boundaries for
yourself and decide how are you going to
use your money your talent your time in
such a way that it's going to serve you
first because if you if it doesn't allow
you to be filled up then you get
depleted and you no longer doing it so
my decisions are now emotional and
logical meaning I choose education but I
do it in such a way that's actually
going to benefit the person that I'm
serving then it's not just oh I would
help people you know yeah thank you
so to move on to our last part you said
at the end of your 25 years gratitude is
the thingis single greatest treasure I
will take with me from this experience
so now you've started your own network
and you continue to be very involved in
your philanthropy and your school is
there anything left that you're scared
to try whoa Amanda you must have been up
all night left that I'm scared to try no
no and I'm just trying to think of what
I'm trying to think well this is there
something that I hadn't thought it was
there's not much you haven't done well
but I stay in my lane yeah I stay I know
what my lane is I know what my lane is I
know that my real calling is what I said
earlier it's not I know what it looks
like to the rest of the world other talk
shows doesn't but I really know what I'm
here to do which is the number one thing
I would say to you the first let me
answer your question so no there's
nothing I'm not I'm not scared to try I
haven't even I have hit my stride but I
haven't done what I ultimately came to
do there still is a supreme moment of
destiny that awaits me and I also knew
that during the Oprah Show
I kept it I've kept a journal since I
was 15 years old it's so pitiful when
you go back and see how pathetic you
were as a person sometimes but I always
knew even during that show that the show
we live in a Fame culture we live in a
Fame centered world you know had this
literally been during the Renaissance
people would have value different things
if we'd been during the
transcendentalist period people value
different things but in our culture we
value Fame so I always understood that
that was the basis for me being known in
the world because people wouldn't be
able to hear you unless you came with
some swag or swagger you know and I also
understood that that was just the
foundation to be heard but that there
was a lot more to be said so for me
owning a network or being a part of a
network is about continuing to use that
platform to to raise the consciousness I
do a show on Sundays which you can
stream live called super soul Sunday
where I literally talked to thought
leaders from around the world and asked
the questions not as good as you I'm
gonna consult with you ask the questions
in life that really matter to get people
thinking about what really matters in
their lives and the responses that I get
from people just regarding that show let
me know that I'm on the right track I'm
moving in the right direction and so I'm
not afraid because I know that all of us
have limited time here but the real
question is who are you and what do you
want to do with it and how are you gonna
use who you are my favorite line from
from from seed of the soul is when the
personality comes to serve the energy of
your soul that is authentic empowerment
so as graduates of this great school to
take what you've learned here to take
what is a part of your
nature and what you've developed as
skills and what you what really feeds
your your passion to take that and to
align that with the deeper potential and
possibility of your souls coming when
you align your personality with what
your soul King dick and everybody has it
aligned your personality with your
purpose and nobody can touch you and you
wake up every day and you are fired up
you just right because everybody has a
purpose so your whole thing is to figure
out what that is your real job is to
figure out why you're really here and
then get about the business of doing
that that's it so we all know now what
we have to do right
yeah so I Oprah thank you so much are we
gonna take some questions yeah so that's
what I wanted to say everybody has a
class at 1:15 right okay I'll get you
out of here they told me hard out one
o'clock but um so I think we have do you
have a first question from Twitter
coming throughout the session the first
question else today was Matt's Acedo who
asked will you marry me
[Applause]
we map where's the ring Matt do we do
what do we do we need marriage
oh my god that's going to be such a
prenup between us I guess
and and then we had Javier Hernandez who
asked Oprah who has been your favorite
interviewee and why well actually
I would have to say there's so many over
the years and the truth is that the
people whose names that I can't even
remember and you probably wouldn't
remember have been the most revelatory
the most impactful I mean watching
people step out of tragedies in in in in
define triumph for themselves those
people really have been the ones that
really shaped me and made me a better
human being I did an interview once with
a woman and actually with dr. Phil where
she had come to the show and it was
planning to kill herself afterwards she
said because her daughter had been
murdered eight years before and she
couldn't get past it and she just wanted
to come on on the Oprah show and talk
about it and Phil said to her why do you
spend all your time lamenting all these
years of lamenting the death instead of
celebrating the life you've let the one
day define your daughter's entire life
and she looked up at him and she said
you know I never thought about it that
way before with tears I could feel that
that the shift in her so the most
important moments for me have been when
literally I can see that somebody has
made a shift in the way they see
themselves in the world or you know what
we call now an aha moment those I live
for that I live for that those are those
are my favorite interviews but most
recently I just last week interviewed
Pharrell Oh
crappy
but you made him cry I didn't make him
cry I didn't make him cry but he cried
and it was but it was happy tears yeah I
would have to say I don't go after I
don't I don't like even try to make
people cry and if I and if I think
literally we cut a lot of it because he
went into the ugly cry he went in
through the ugly yeah it was very well
and so we said we gotta say the brother
brother cannot walk out into the world
he cried it's okay to have a little
sniffle sniffle but I could also heal
him I mean I understand you know why
because I just loved him
I just loved him anybody who and anybody
who saw that interview if you liked him
a little bit before you really loved him
afterwards because that's a person who's
absolutely connected yeah he knows his
very much connected to it and when he
saw he started crying when he saw the
videos of people all over the world
dancing to the happy song it was a
version made here to here yeah you guys
did one too yeah I think some of the NBA
ones right raise your hand if you were
in it yeah didn't it make you happy to
do it yeah so he saw that video like 30
seconds of video from people in all
these different countries in the name of
the countries were up and he just felt
the emotion and the impact of using his
life in such a way that you're able now
to touch all of those people which is
really what we're all looking to do and
all of us have the ability to do it at
whatever level you are at whatever level
and I always say to people oh I have a
big stage some people have a smaller
stage some people have you know what's
your stage we're gonna take one from the
audience now yeah yeah all right
introduce yourself hi I'm Kirsten I'm a
second year MBA student here at the GSB
so this week at the GSB we're hosting
something called climate week to raise
awareness about climate change among the
business students here and so you've
interviewed people like Leo the Al Gore
President Obama on
this really important issue and so I
want to see it get a sense from you of
how do you navigate raising the level of
consciousness around issues like climate
change that are important but also very
complex and politicized hey Cambridge we
came prepared today huh Wow
I do not know the answer
if I knew that we would I would've like
made it a club and we I would have
everybody come join my environment all
club no I don't know that is such a
complex beautiful question and the fact
that you were even asking it or engaged
in the process of trying to figure out
the answer thrills me because that's
what would happen here at Stanford so
but I I really do not have an answer to
that question
thank you have time for one more you
have to because you can't hand on a
question again sir
I came just came here to get good
stumped yeah hi Oprah my name is Melissa
and I wanted to know how do you think
about balancing selflessness with
selfishness self less deaths with
selfishness why are you asking me that
question it's kind of the the tension
between putting yourself first and also
taking care of others okay well I would
say this there is no you have know
everybody's heard the whole oxygen mask
thing the truth is you don't have
anything to give that you don't have so
you have to keep your own self full
that's your job you know one of my
daughter's is here today from Oprah
Winfrey Leadership Academy stand up
today so everybody can see
[Applause]
you're gonna end your first year soon oh
my god first year I say to the my girls
all of the time that your real work is
to figure out where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's the number one thing
you have to do is to work on yourself
and to fill your self up and keep your
cup full keep yourself full now I used
to be afraid of that I used to be afraid
particularly from people who say oh she
said she's so full of herself or so and
now I embrace it I considered a
compliment that I am full of myself
because you only when you're full I'm
full I'm overflowing my cup runneth over
I have so much I have so much to offer
and so much to give and I am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it first
of all for me my father and mother never
married they had sex one time underneath
an oak tree because she was wearing a
poodle skirt in 1953 and my dad to this
day says I want to know what's under
that skirt that's what I won't know
you want to know what was under the
skirt they didn't really have a
relationship she wanted one but you know
he went under the skirt and then that
was it
and one time under the oak tree BAM
Renaissance that's why I know my life is
bigger than that my life has to be
bigger as yours is bigger than a moment
then that poodle skirt it's much bigger
the design the the reason why I'm here
is much bigger than oh I think I want to
see what's under that so the ability to
take care of that to honor that to honor
yourself and that which is greater than
yourself that which was the reason for
your being here that that there's no
selflessness in that because only
through that do you have the ability to
offer yourself your whole self your full
expression of who you are to the rest of
the world so I remember the very first
time I had a life coach they weren't
call that at the time but it's expert on
who shared with our audience the women
she did a list and say where are you on
the list and literally in that audience
women booed her when she said put
yourself top of the list this was in
1992 in 1992 the idea of being top of
the your own list was people like oh she
doesn't have children I said she didn't
say abandon your children and go running
in the streets she just said put
yourself at the top of the list nurture
yourself honor yourself stop the crazy
mind chatter in your head that tells you
all the time that you're not good enough
because that's the number one I found to
issue with everybody the reason people
say you know how was that how was that
it's because you want to know how do you
measure up well to know that your just
being here your just being here however
that sperm BAM hit that egg however that
occurred for you that your being here is
such a miraculous thing and that your
real job is to honor that is to honor
that and the sooner you figure that out
oh wow
wow I'm one of the lucky ones I got to
be here so how do you continue to
prepare yourself to live out the highest
fullest truest expression of yourself as
a human being and I just want to end
with this yeah there are no mistakes
there really aren't any because you have
a supreme destiny when you're in your
little mind in your little personality
mind where you're not centered
you really don't know who you are that
you come from something greater and
bigger and that we're really all are the
same you don't know that you get all
flustered you get stressed all the time
wanting something to be what it isn't
there's a supreme moment of destiny
calling on your life your job is to feel
that to hear that to know that and
sometimes when you're not listening you
get taken off track you get in the wrong
marriage the wrong relationship you take
the wrong job yeah but it's all leading
to the same path there are no wrong
paths there are none there's no such
thing as failure really because failure
is just that thing trying to move you in
another direction so you get as much
from your losses as you do from your
victories because the losses are there
to wake you up the losses are to say oh
that is why you go to school
so that CBS can call you so when you
understand that you don't allow yourself
to be completely thrown by a grade or by
a circumstance because your life is
bigger than anyone experience and if I
had I always ask people on super soul
Sunday to tell me what would you say to
your younger self every person says in
one form or another I would have said
relax relax it's gonna be okay
it really is gonna be okay because even
if you're on a Doody tour right now and
and that's how you know when you're not
at ease with yourself when you're
feeling like oh no to me that that is
the cue that you need to be moving in
another direction don't let yourself get
all thrown off continue to be thrown off
course when you're feeling off-course
that's the key how do I turn around so
when everybody was talking about when I
started this network if I had only known
good Lord how difficult it would be the
way through the challenge is to get
still and ask yourself what is the next
right move not think about it oh I got
all of this stuff what is the next right
move and then from that space make the
next right move and the next right move
and not to be overwhelmed by it because
you know your life is bigger than that
one moment you know you're not defined
by what somebody says is a failure for
you because failure is just there to
point you in a different direction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]